Pokemon go is a worldwide phenomenon but  that doesn't mean that it's available in  every territory I'm Tony at this game  spot news update can't quite catch them  all Iran has become the first country to  officially banned pokemon go Iran's High  Council of virtual spaces is in charge  of filtering online content and it is  decided to ban the game for security  purposes considering the number of  disturbances that have happened as a  result of Pokemon go you can sort of  understand where the High Council is  coming from and despite the band plenty  of Iranian citizens are already playing  and discussing the game Iran's  population is over 79 million so that's  a big potential market for Pokemon go  perhaps the restriction will lift in the  future but for now those players will  have to train under the radar to keep up  with all the latest pokemon news  including the fall release of sun and  moon you already in the right place